[Music]
um thank you for making it all the way
over here I know you had to hoof it over
from Moscone so I appreciate you
swinging by today I want to talk about
GK on-prem which is all part of the new
name is what yell it out and those there
we go all right excellent good the
marketing is working so yeah so we're
gonna talk about and it will obviously
touch on anthos a bit as well because if
you can't talk about GK I'm Prem without
a little bit anthos so we'll touch on
that a bit my name is Matt Tavis I'm a
Solutions Architect what that means is I
spend most of my time either writing
things down about how to use this stuff
or working with customers and telling
how to use this stuff so that's
basically what I do and I might focus
specifically is in the hybrid space so
I've actually spent a fair amount of
time with the the PM team on the anthos
product suite talking to them about what
these products can look like how they're
gonna roll out how people should play
with them and so today I'm gonna talk a
bit about GK on-prem and then
specifically I'll show you that actually
functioning outside of the cloud on an
environment set up on packet comm and
then we'll do some demos there a little
bit and then I will turn it over to BS
palm borg who's actually one of our
customers who's already used this for
his business you know tell you more
about that so that's the plan for this
morning so just a quick recap put this
in here for the people that are reading
on the recording
mostly you've seen this it's about GK
on-prem but also even how you can tie
that into more of a CSV pipeline
actually how config management and get
can actually be used as a way to even
control your clusters and manage them as
well
so both those will be covered in today's
session so let's start with why we
actually even have in this conversation
begin with so GK and Prem is obviously a
on-prem version of gke who uses gke
today
excellent so we got it we got a lot of
kubernetes folks here to understand it
g/km prem is the idea of bringing that
to the to a platform other than Google
and so that's because although there's
many people have mandated public clouds
they want to use them 73% but 10 only
10% of workloads have actually moved
over so there's still almost 90 percent
of workloads and many enterprises that
are still in on Prem environments so how
do you unlock the
the potential of the using the latest
cloud technologies but in those on-prem
environments and so some have even moved
you know data back in some cases so we
actually have to contend with this
there's always going to be some element
of hybrid in most enterprises they're
not just gonna pick everything up and
just move it all the cloud tomorrow and
even if they do it's gonna be a
transitional period so hybrid is really
pragmatic and persistent and so G Kia
and Prem is an opportunity to bring some
of that cloud technology into your
existing on-prem on-premises
infrastructure now that shows up in a
lot of ways there's a lot of reasons why
you might have to even continue in that
path over time so for example let's say
you really want to unlock the cloud for
your development teams you want CI CD
you want full automation pipelines you
ought to use the latest tools and
technologies you want to give them dev
environments that they can turn up with
a snap right but it turns out when you
go to run it in production it's on a
ship or it's in a store or it's in a
factory right you actually have this
split model if I need to be able to
build locally in the cloud and then I
need to push to someplace else
so the GKN prem is giving you containers
everywhere that's that model another
model that requires hybrid and requires
this kind of mix environment is
jurisdictional I'm using I'm writing
code but fundamentally the actual
execution or even the data itself has to
live in a specific location there's
rules about where it can reside and
therefore I need the cloud technologies
close to my data which has to stay in a
certain spot where maybe there isn't a
cloud data center that's another common
model and then the third we sing quite
often is even as best-of-breed services
i want to run some things local against
my data sets that are there but then I
also want to tap into say machine
learning or you know data warehousing
technologies so I want to bridge these
architectures where I have a local
execution then I actually tap into a
data set in the cloud or are a certain
function in the cloud and so all these
are reasons why you might actually end
up having a hybrid scenario and why you
might need something like GK on prom in
Swoopes anthos once called cloud
services platform now called anthos and
the idea here is it's a collection of
cloud services but it's also a
collection of marketplace components and
we'll see some of that you get actually
tie into the existing GCP marketplace
both for in the cloud
but also in the on private environment
as well as the control plane the idea
being that once you've taken this leap
into using this this hybrid model it
goes everywhere you can now run that the
same way you'd rather our GCP you wrote
it on prom of the same tools and
technologies the same back-end services
and other clouds so that is the
long-term goal here so we'll talk about
how it looks today a little more and so
the fundamentals of that platform but
really the reason why we think this
makes sense and what we've been hearing
from a lot of our customers about why
this is something they want one it's
this ability to modernize in place
I want to leverage the latest in you
know development technologies such as
you know containers or kubernetes or
even things like sto for service mesh
management but I want to do it where I
have my infrastructure today I want to
learn how to modernize what I have as
opposed to having to move everything to
the cloud first the second reason why
people are liking this approach
fundamentally is the ability to automate
policy and security at scale so some of
these components in this platform such
as say SEO for service mesh for managing
your access between individual
components or elements in your container
architecture or config management which
allows you to automatically apply
configuration to your clusters or about
the ability to manage that sprawl that
you see that starts to occur when you
have micro services and containers in
lots of different places how do I keep a
consistent policy on top of that how do
I have a consistent security profile and
a security stance and configuration
stance everywhere that's another another
goal of what the anthos platform is
really focused on and the last is really
that consistent experience not really so
much for your users but for your
operators for your developers and for
your administrators so they have a
consistent set of tools a consistent
approach that they take everywhere so
they're not learning different
technologies different tools on each
cloud or platform they use their will
any one set one tool chain across the
board so they're writing code the same
way no matter where it runs they're
running the same kinds of scripts for
automation no matter where it's actually
functioning and then ultimately I have
the same you know dashboard of
visibility of what's happening
everywhere
no matter where that that code is
running tomorrow is where it's being
developed
or deploy that's fundamentally that the
goal of the overall platform and this is
sorta a little view into it to give you
a sense of all the pieces that play in
there and we'll talk we're gonna talk
more about the GKN prem is in that
bottom right you see that's that's where
we've deployed some you know gke to a
specific cluster but there's more to it
when you look at the full platform in
terms of things like additional services
you might tap into say stack driver or
cloud run which was talked about this
morning in the keynote binary
authorization for the ability to sign
and certify container images and code
your deploy write all those things are
additional services you might add on to
your deployment if you feel they're
appropriate those can run both is sort
of a split model a little bit in the
cloud a little bit in your on-prem
environment and then there's this
marketplace component I mentioned you
saw actually probably in the first days
keynote there was a moment where they
showed just drop a drop down selecting
say cloudBees and hitting a button and
go and that deploys it to your cluster
the idea is that the GCP marketplace
that's there is tied directly and so you
can deploy even purchased software paid
components directly to your clusters
whether they be on primer in the cloud
and then below that we have that control
plane layer we're going to talk a little
bit about the three there's three big
pieces in there config management the
connect layer and then of course the
service mesh which is akin to sto and
sort of a managed service mesh layer
Jiki on-prem is that bottom right box
right there and it's really about
bringing the cloud style automation to
an on-premises model right so big
elements of why this makes a lot of
sense is instead of you know patching
upgrading and troubleshooting your
cluster you can simply rebuild and
deploy right it's it's much more
automated in terms of control
in terms of getting that rolled out and
you can programmatically provision and
scale that infrastructure so because now
you've got tied into the GK on-prem
interface which looks very much like the
cube CTL there's a new thing called gke
CTL and it will go ahead and spin up new
clusters and actually upgrade versions
of your kubernetes running on top of it
for you so does the automation of that
provisioning of infrastructure as part
of that and it also will upgrade
software by controllers not manually so
now you're actually are getting the
deployment of
the latest versions of kubernetes the
exact same versions that are running on
gke in your on-prem environment so
there's no worries about version
mismatch across your platform and so
that comparisons have you look at it gke
versus GK and Prem I think I'll skip the
gke side because I think sounds like a
lot of folks come to know what's out
there but you know big notes to make her
that GK he's been in GA since August of
2015 so long-standing consumption usage
pattern it's fully managed kubernetes
control plan takes care of a lot of
those things for you
now on the GK on Prem side you'll see
now you're getting turnkey production
grade conforming kubernetes with best
practice configuration so what that
means is we're just like with gke where
we're giving you kubernetes versions to
choose from that have been vetted and
verified same thing happens with a GK a
problem you're using the same versions
of the open source communities platform
that runs in both environments there's
an easy upgrade path is it validated and
tested releases of kubernetes so you
know you're picking something that's
already been tested and verified and of
course you will still have access to all
those container services that use in the
cloud so you can still use container
registry you can still use you know
cloud build for automation audit logging
pieces like that as well as you know
stack driver and other services however
you can also use your own so there's no
reason why you couldn't set up your own
private container registry on Prem and
point to that instead of GCR right
there's no reason why you couldn't have
your own you know build pipelines that
you run locally and then deploy through
those in your on-prem environment so
you're not tied to those services but
they're available to you so you have
flexibility in choice I think choice is
the word we used a lot yesterday to
describe those choices what it's really
about giving you options and of course
you have full integration with various
other open-source components like say
sto also managed through cloud service
mesh which is a as part of the endless
umbrella Kay native which is then also
talked about as cloud run I'm seeing
this parallel where the open source
projects are also that available as
offerings to the ansatz platform and
then the marketplace solutions as well
so in terms of consistency you know the
G cavers GM
time you see there's a lot of similar
bit similarities here operating systems
on-premise abun to versus the container
optimized OS there's some minor tool
differences the consoles the same cube
cuddles the same or cube CTL depending
on what way you like to pronounce that
g-cloud swaps out for gke CTL so gke
cuddle which allows you to spit up a new
cluster and that's how you deploy user
clusters inside the environment calico
is consistent across you've got stack
driver you've got efk and g'kar brown
but you can also use stock driver
logging you can use whatever logging
tools you want for monitoring Prometheus
and Gore fauna are deployed
automatically but you can add
stackdriver plugins as well if you want
that so you have the ability to keep it
separate and isolated or to actually
bridge it in with the existing services
that GK uses as well what it kind of
looks like and this is the this is what
we call the cube ception model clusters
within clusters when you were to employ
GK on Prem
fundamentally you build out first in
administrative cluster it's that top box
right that admin cluster has its virtual
machines that are the control plane and
then actually sort of if you will
masters in a sort of the quoted sense
air quoted sense they are actually
control plane nodes for the user
clusters then have elements that follow
any that so there's an admin cluster
that creates other clusters there's the
way to think about that so when you go
ahead and run gke cuddle to save spend
up a user cluster it will talk to that
admin control plane which works directly
with in v1 the vCenter api's so it works
directly with the VMware vCenter guys to
automatically provision new VMs as well
as working directly with in this case f5
they got peed at provision network
address space and register addresses for
external access to the cluster right
we'll cover some of the networking
components in a second but fundamentally
that is a fully automated deployment of
a whole new cluster those images are
spin up they have kubernetes
pre-installed in them they come online
they join the cluster and you can
actually control the size and sand
sizing of those VMs we need to ploy so
it's all baked in a configuration that
you can run once to do a dry run and
then go ahead
deploy automatically so then you can
create multiple user clusters so if
today you might be using different
clusters for different teams or
different services you'd do the same
thing on Prem you spent up user cluster
for Team X or user cluster for Team Y
and then they have completely isolated
clusters that you can control
individually and then you can use DHCP
or static IP controls to decide how you
can allocate addresses so you have a
little bit control there from a
networking perspective and networking is
one area where this is different we'll
cover that in just a second because we
have this diagram which I'm sure
everyone's going on a photo of don't
worry it's coming the video too but the
the idea here is that networking is one
thing that's quite different with g/km
Prem so when you think about gke running
on the cloud you also have it as full
control to the network infrastructure
upon which it runs that means it's
allowed to you know set up load
balancers and make sure the routing
between IP ranges is set up and the IP
address rules or the IP filtering rules
firewall rules were all configured
automatically for you when you look at
this running in your on-prem environment
inside the cluster things work great all
all the components inside the cluster
can see each other but then things
coming from the outside have to access
those services inside so that's where
there's a subtle difference and that's
why there's a a initially this is this
is in my example in this slide it's
using f5 longer term there's a goal to
bring your own load balancer that you
might choose as opposed to that so this
will be a model where the what happens
is the when you're spinning up the
cluster it creates the node IP spa type
ease and service IP addresses are all
automatically created based on the
ranges you give it you allocate the ten
dot range or whatever a private IP range
you want and then it'll also as part of
that spin up process allocate the
ingress IP or the ingress VIP the
service VIP and the control plane VIPs
in f5 so now all of those services that
you might deploy or all the components
you might deploy are accessible from
outside the cluster so other components
in your network inside your your your
on-prem data center can now see those
you choose what you expose just like you
choose what you expose and gke by
exposing a service and making it you
know available same concepts you're
still exposing a load balancer but
you're choosing a particular IP range
that's known by the f5 so it could
actually expose that out to the rest of
the the data center will actually take a
look at that just a second the other
thing that comes with this is because
that's great now you've got kubernetes
running in your data center but you
probably still want to see what's
happening you still want to have that
kind of visibility and so there's a
component that is optional you choose to
add it
it's called GK connect the hub it is a
essentially used something you deploy
into that cluster and what it does is it
registers that cluster with the GCP
platform so now that cluster shows up in
your console just like any other cluster
you have writing so now you can see oh
here's my GK cluster and US central 1a
and here's my GK cluster running in on
Prem right right next to each other
dive right in now the way that works is
it will actually install an agent inside
the GK I'm from cluster and then that
agent will actually dial back using the
G RPC TLS connection so it's encrypted
dial back you actually embed secrets in
there so it's it's a it's safe it's part
of the manifest that is given to you
with during the registration what
happens is it will actually call back to
GCP and then announce hey here's how I'm
doing here's my my alerts here's what's
going on with my services here's the
info on my my nodes and my pods and
storage all that kind of stuff is
reported back up so you can see it right
there in the console if you want to it
also gives you the ability to feed
deployment information back down so from
the console you can deploy things
directly into an on-prem cluster another
thing that we're actually to take a look
at in fact let's take a look at that
right now so what we have here is this
the packet environment I set up so
impact it all I did was obviously this
is a demo so I didn't you know want to
spend too much money so I just spun up
one big machine that has a lot of
available a so it's got you know 64 gigs
ram you know some SSDs on there 24 core
processor
so sizeable good enough to let me run my
environment what's on there though the
most important thing that start is I've
actually got VMR running on there and so
I've got an environment there set up
which actually manages all the VMware
infrastructure so you can see all the
virtual machines in here just like that
picture before you've got you know admin
workstation
you've got the f5 Service appliance
you've got master nodes the admin master
nodes you've got a network services VM
that handles sort of natty and routing
between that environment now this is a
specific configuration for this demo it
doesn't have to run exactly like that
but and then there's the user cluster
component sitting there and a vCenter
appliance so that's what we have sitting
in there in terms of that infrastructure
so what that gives me is the ability to
go over here and say you know cube cube
cuddle get pods all - namespaces so you
can see here I now have all these
individual things running automatically
I've got the GK connect agent already in
there that's great
I've got sto is already pre-installed in
there we easiest do for some layer 7
routing inside of GK on Prem you can
obviously have a full H do deployment as
well with all the components alert
managers Calico is in there you see
configuration management we'll talk
about that a little bit cube proxies
there's some f5 load mounts from mapping
Prometheus's in there so you've got
logging built in baked in the cluster
now the other thing that happens of
course as I mentioned is that you could
actually see this cluster
directly in the console I'll reconnect
that guy and we'll come back to him in a
second so if I go back here to
kubernetes engine I could see in my
clusters that there's my user cluster 1
and my location is SJC right so that's
not actually AG key or AG hijiki domain
and so I can jump in here and you can
actually see even on the storage
information right here like you can see
there's
this is datastore one q-ball's you know
VMDK so it's mapping to the actual
storage that's provided underneath the
covers as part of the vm RV center setup
so you've got the the storage in there
and then of course you even have the
nodes information in here and then so
you have each of the nodes what's
available for CPUs you know at 8 gigs
I'm only 2.6 is used and I can dive into
an individual node and see the actual
detail what's running here's all the
components of the running here's the CPU
it's available I can even see my
conditions about you know is it failing
any checks on disk pressure or or
insufficient memory and things like that
all visible right there in the console
right I can also go ahead and if I'm
really daring because well hey why not
I'm here the internet seems to be
working this is awesome let's do it I
can also just deploy stuff directly from
here I'm into that cluster so let's just
go ahead to play engine X cuz that's
fairly straightforward and we'll call it
edge next one that makes sense
and there's user cluster one see it's in
the list is user cluster one which is
the one that I have running on Prem and
I can go ahead and deploy right there
and then we watch and stare and cross
our fingers and tap the table and cross
our toes and OH
first first green checkmark second green
checkmark and I'm gonna go for that it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen waiting
for pods waiting for pods
all right so that is deployed so now if
I were a our gke I could be like oh
that's sweet see resigned your next one
that's awesome
I'm just gonna tap in here and go cool
let's expose it because that's what I
would do our gke right
just hit expose there's only one
challenge there which is that if you
view this yeah mole you'll see that
there's no load balance or IP right so
because what's gonna happen in GK is
it's just gonna figure it out and it's
gonna give you one it's gonna fake it no
problem it's all taken care of GK on
Prem you got to be a lot more specific
you actually that's where the f5 comes
in that's where you have to say oh use
this IP from my f5 I've pre-allocated
right so I can't do it exactly like this
but don't worry I've got it all figured
out wow that's oh that's not exactly
true I don't think I've all figured out
but I got a couple things in my head
going on so let's go over here and pop
into this is that machine and so I
actually have I will do a cat engine
oops engine ex-service yeah mo so I've
got a service animal so the subtle
difference here is that now I've got a
load balancer IP at the bottom there
I picked one no I'm so that's ten 0.10
bout 252 now you'll probably notice
that's not routable either but it turns
out there's a little funny little box
that network services admin in my lab
environment that does some mapping
between internal and external IPS keeps
my life straight in a production setup
you'd actually have a load balancer out
there on the edge that's actually doing
the mapping from the outside of the
inside IP range is gonna be fired or
you'd have a public Ward you could
choose right here but I can do that as I
can a cube cuddle apply this is when you
find out if I really know what I'm doing
it's a big test so just create that
service which is great and that service
is on this port right there so there you
go
now that's the public IP range from the
packet environment that's being mapped
Ngata directly into the internal so
there you go I've deployed nginx I've
got a load balancer that's picking up
that traffic and then riding as the
internal workload I know you're stunned
don't fall out of your chest
all right let's go let's go back to the
let's go back to the presentation
but of course the challenge here is
managing multi cloud hybrid environments
is super difficult right because you've
got all sorts of central IT and
government's rules people want to apply
they want make sure it's consistent
everywhere and this is just creating
sprawl right it's adding you know now a
single person single node or cluster has
multiple containers and layers of layers
of containers and micro-services it adds
a lot of complexity so you know what
they really want in central IT is this
change control the one accountability
they want you know consistent
environment configurations they want to
ensure consistency to the single source
is truth right and so they want to be
able to remediate problems quickly
should something happen even across
multiple environments around the world
so by adding this this flexibility we're
also adding complexities so how we're
gonna solve that that's the real
question so that's where anthos config
management comes in anthos config
management you probably saw this in the
keynote I don't know if anyone was
paying attention there was a there was a
one point in keynote where they said get
push you know on one of the one of the
console screens and one catch that
anyone see they get push yeah so that
get push is this alright it's config
management it's basically saying look
let's just use git as a single source of
truth and let's make the clusters all
watch a repository and then grab the
configuration they need for their setup
so the idea here is you can sync your
configs across all your clusters both on
prem and in the cloud
and this enables continuous
configuration of enforcement on policies
so you can say here's the for these
namespaces for these clusters these are
the yamo files you have to apply it's in
a repo it automatically happens and so
if things change it'll go back and look
at that repo and be like Oh something
changed I gotta update the cluster if
you try and make changes to the cluster
that disagree with the repo it will get
them back to what the repo says right so
it actually will keep make sure that
environment stays in sync and we'll see
that in just a minute I have more demos
yes I know
get comfortable most chairs don't fall
off and so and this gives you your audit
ability through policies code so now you
can also apply you know
you're your own checks your own controls
your own pipelines on top of that repo
that allow you to make sure the right
people are doing it they're going for
the right checks and policies there's
even a tool associated with this that
will vet your configuration before you
deploy it so make sure it actually will
will work right so there's some
components in there and so the idea here
though is it's really adopting that
configures code model it allows that
anthos admin somebody who's accesses
policy repository to make sure they set
up the environment consistently across
the board and so this is you know kind
of an example there's a as part of the
DOCSIS rolls out you'll see this example
there's a policy repo and you can see
there's you know food corp being sort of
a top-level namespace with online being
a namespace shipping app back-end being
a namespace now the online is more
virtual because it's really nothing
inside of it but as you get down to say
shipping - debussy there's a job creator
role binding yeah Mon job create a role
yeah namespace camel quota Yambol you
know a whole bunch of Yambol files in
here and basically anything you can do
to a cluster with a cube cuddle apply
you know yeah mole type command is
something you could mock up as config as
well so you can actually do you know
role bindings you can do deployments you
can do service deployments workloads
whatever it makes sense and so the idea
here is that you can then use your
classic configuration formats the Amal
files and then go ahead and put those
into get as a repo and then it plugs it
easily into your Vallot into your CI CD
pipeline for you know making sure that
it's valid and incorrect as you go so
the way this kind of works is you might
have you know in your in your gke
platform you can have the config
management operator so this is
implemented as a kubernetes operator
which it basically is then keeping track
of a git compliant repo right your repo
could be on Prem and your g/km Prem has
the operator and installed it's syncing
against that repo just like the gke is
as well so if your if your repo is
accessible to the gke then you can use
one repo you can also use say github or
get a private git repo if you want
deploy it in the cloud and then use that
as your point as well also you can use
google source repositories so let's take
a look at that let's jump over the demo
all right so that was exciting so the
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm actually
gonna install config management so what
I'm gonna do is show you that looks like
it's pretty simple little script it all
it does here is it's doing a cube cuddle
apply right
it's basically applying the latest
version of this release the old name was
know most it's not called config
management it installs a get credentials
so I'm using SSH credentials I've
actually installed them in the cluster
so they can find those quickly so it can
access the repo
and then I just apply a config
management yamo and if we cap that
you'll see that's fairly straightforward
it's pointing to you know here's my user
cluster what I want to call it here's
the endpoint you know that I want you to
go to the SSH endpoint for the actual
repo itself you know sync with master
always use master you know and then I'm
gonna use SSH for that so the way I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do it Stoll
config management and don't worry
there'll be an error but that's okay I
know about that error I've already
installed the creds they were already in
there so install them again doesn't work
obviously so that's now going so what's
gonna happen is it's gonna start
immediately looking at that repo so if I
go in here and I go back to clusters I'm
sorry I go to workloads okay there will
be a couple new things in here already
and that's the config management you can
see there's the get importer there's a
sinker there's monitor these are part of
that config management system and these
will start you know deploying themselves
once they're in their setup working
they're gonna start talking about repo
and then looking for what needs to
happen now while that's going on because
that's not instantaneous as you could
imagine as much as I'd like it to be
I'll show you quickly kind of what that
repo looks like so you get a sense of
what's going on in there there's a
couple of areas in this repo that are
worth noting there's the cluster
registry area and here you can actually
set up your clusters so the reason why
you might do this is because you might
have different environments that have
different sets of
rules and I'll show you how that plays
out in the config but you can register
your clusters here and then as you add
them you say oh here's the parameters I
want you to use for this cluster that
flows down into your namespaces
definition to pick the right versions of
of elements as an example if we go into
namespaces and we go into the Kate's
manifests you'll see in here if I can
find it and this is all the different
things that are in here so here's the
gke on-prem on packet you see right and
so what I'm doing is I'm doing a cluster
selector saying if it's a packet cluster
then I want you to do something
different and what's different here is
really not much different down here I
added an environment platform variable
that I want to show up on that cluster
specifically it changes how the code
operates in that cluster we'll see how
that happens in a second I also have if
I go down here also on packet I have the
load balancer setup so you'll see here I
actually added the load balancer IP like
we talked about earlier I have to have a
load balancer IP and g/km Prem whereas I
don't have that for for the the on GK so
for one gke it looks like this there's
no there's no load balancer IP right so
let's take a look and make sure that's
actually happening it's refresh here
okay yeah look wow it actually worked
that was sorry that wasn't shocked iPod
that was enthusiasm
it wasn't a totally different thing no
it work it works fine it was fine yeah
no it's a it's good it's great it's um
it's but it's all set up so Laurel green
already and one thing you'll notice is
right here front end external is set to
load balancer 10 0 10 251 : 80 and so if
I go to that URL which is not here
that's not 29 but actually 28 there you
go so we've got the hip-stir
it was called hipster not called online
boutique same thing you saw in the in
the keynote same app it's actually the
same codebase I just pulled it down for
this environment um so you could see the
same
and you can see this on premises here
that's because that's actually tied to
the where the environments running
that's that variable is passed again on
Prem versus GK so I can set that
differently and said the load balance of
differently for each one and work just
fine alright let's go back to the deck
now that's all very exciting and and
that's actually all I'm gonna share with
you this morning what you probably were
edged into is like what are people
actually doing with this stuff that's me
showing a demo app that we built that
everyone can do and download on their
own fun stuff however right now I'd like
to introduce you to Tobias palm bug who
is the CTO of mittens who's one of our
early customers of gk yun from and he's
gonna tell you more about what their
team did with it
thanks man thank you
and thanks for an awesome presentation I
mean I can do those demos so very nice
work thanks for having me here I'm super
keen on being here and it's been super
key interesting to get an early view on
Gigi on premise we're back so I'm gonna
try and walk you through a little bit of
what how we were thinking about it and
what we're doing with it but first of
all so Tobias my name I'm CEO of nest
egg and nest and for those who you don't
know we're b2b company within sort of
the online casino gaming industry we
produce games I have a slot machine ran
on me today we have a number of titles
that we've done we produce about what we
have right now about 200 games live so
we produce those games and reproduce a
platform that runs those games for our
customers and our customers they are
operators in the online casino industry
the the important part here and it's
really what Matt showed before and in
the early slide stream the reason why
we're looking into this and it's the
URIs diction on reason right that's our
main one net tenth has about twenty
eight licenses across our market so and
the gambling industries is sort of going
through a pretty fast v regulation I
would say regulators however are not the
most modern people right now
so going clout is not it's not something
that we can do in all places right until
last year pretty much because then we
saw a pretty big shift in some of the
regulators so cloud was more and more
okay to use right the problem for us
then was that it was only some so if we
were to go cloud at that point we would
end up in that position where you have
on Prem that looks in one way and then
go in cloud looks a completely different
way right and with regards to our
complexity I'm going to go through that
a little bit more later on we kind of
said that we don't want to take that
path we're not ready for that
can add yet another layer of complexity
so we decided to stay on prep until we
got to know about geeky on-prem and got
some early access to and it looks really
promising and what Matt's shown is
really what's going to help us to have
that sort of single control plane and
still be able to use both on Prem and G
key just some numbers around what I call
our complexity so I said 200 customers
we build what we call a casino module
for each and every customer so each
customer has at least one a casino
module so we have 500 casino modules
translate into something around 3,500
VMs so it's quite a lot to keep track on
we have 10 data centers around the world
to support this and support the licenses
we have and as I said we 200 games
adding new games adding new customers
it's kind of like the complexity is it's
it's just increasing a lot so adding
that hybrid without having really
control of it would be really hard for
us these are current debt data centers
and we're growing and we are setting one
right up setting one up right now in
Pennsylvania for the opening of that
market the beauty of how we see Jiki
on-prem for now is that we can set up
our data centers in a different way that
we've done before so we've been working
toward with container platforms and in
kubernetes for the last two years and we
run an open shift or openshift clusters
in all our 10 datacenter and it's not a
trivial thing to do it's quite a lot of
maintenance to do this and we were
looking for a managed service for quite
some time now we got it right so this is
pretty much the sort of kind of
migration path we're looking at you see
the almost si names of he soup so before
on the datacenters the blue boxes are
the
that we're go where we going cloud we
have Finland as one example it's a
regulated market and and so happens to
be that that Google has a data center in
Finland so we're starting there it's up
and running we're looking to move our
admin sites and then we're looking to
build small effective data centers for
where their regulators require sell and
run Jiki on-prem on them I don't have a
fancy demo as my house but I have a
really good video clip from a couple of
weeks back when some of the developers
with us managed to get the first game
rounds played in geeky on-prem and that
was really early so it was alpha so I
want to show you that show some workload
on geeky on-prem alpha we start with
showing that this is an ingress object
that is actually in the G key um from
alpha so we now make Q control CL a
command and we see that we now have an
SP P which is our gaming platform and
it's deployed in antiquey on Prem good
so let's go to the you to the web
browser and let's visit the casino
module you can see it works and now
let's go to the admin page of the casino
module let's login here we have a an
internal test page for our games we will
log in with Swedish player
and no password again and let's start
starburst our most popular game now we
are starting and now we're playing
[Music]
now we're playing on prep
[Music]
okay so that's the demo thank you so you
can almost feel the excitement there
right and it might like look like just a
simple game for you guys but this is
surely surely a game changer for us this
is gonna mean a lot of stuff or a lot of
good things for us when we when we
expand our into new markets and and try
to modernize our platform as we've
started to do so I think that's all for
me again I'm really looking forward to
the rest of what you guys will bring
with antis
[Music]